Arthur Grossman and a staff scientist at
the Carnegie Institution for science
which is on the Stanford campus I went
to Indiana University where I got a PhD
and then I went back to New York to
rockefeller university where i worked on
the biogenesis of chloroplasts lasts in
land plants and in 1982 I accepted a
position at Carnegie so I've been here
for over 30 years now so to me algae are
an untapped source of food and products
that can be used very productively by
humans but they're also one of the most
you know they're incredibly diverse they
cover the planet and we know very little
really about them we know little about
the we're learning more about their
diversity but we don't know the
mechanisms by which them molecular and
the biological mechanisms that that they
that they use to deal with the changing
environment and to deal with the natural
environment the products that we'd get
out of algae are just minimal right now
and I think some of the best oils for
example a made by algae and they could
be used very very beneficial e as food
oils I also think that they will be a
sauce they can be used as a source of
fuel in the future